bienvenidos a reglas de los exponentes
nivel 1 vamos a comenzar haciendo
ejercicios empezaremos con este tenemos
2 a la 3 x 2 a la 5 si el punto lo
usamos también para denotar
multiplicación pero bueno
vamos a empezar el ejercicio primero
haciéndolo de esta manera dos a la 3 es
y 2 a las 5 es 32
así que hacer este ejercicio sería lo
mismo que multiplicar 8 por 32 8 por 32
es 8 por 216 más 8 por 30 que es 240 así
que esto es igual a 256
pero ahora lo que yo te voy a enseñar es
una técnica para trabajar con los
exponentes que nos permita primero no
hacer aritmética como la acabamos de
hacer y segundo poder trabajar con
números con exponentes que sean muy
grandes hacer operaciones con números
más grandes de los que te has imaginado
así que ahora veamos con cuidado que es
2 a la 3 pues 2 a la 3
2 x 2 x 2
2 a la 3 es 2 multiplicado tres veces y
quienes 2 a las 5
bueno pues es lo mismo que poner dos por
dos por dos
por dos por dos claro estos dos se están
multiplicando así que 2 a la 3 por 2 a
las 5
es lo mismo que multiplicar 2 por 2 x 2
por 2 x 2 por 2 x 2 por 2
cuántas veces multiplicamos el 2 bueno
pues veamos tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
así quedó sala 3 por 2 a la 5
es lo mismo que 2 a la
8 y también podríamos pensarlo como que
35 es igual a otro
hagamos otro
esta vez tenemos 7 al cuadrado x 7 a la
cuarta esto es igual a 7 por 7 esto es 7
al cuadrado multiplicado por 7 por 7 por
7 por 7 7 4 veces
que esto es igual a 7
a la sexta
en general cuando estamos multiplicando
números con exponentes con la misma base
y eso es muy importante sólo tendremos
que sumar los exponentes por lo que si
yo tengo 7 a la centésima potencia que
multiplica a 7 a la 50 va potencia y
estarás de acuerdo conmigo que estos son
números muy grandes y necesitaríamos una
computadora para hacer las operaciones
esto será lo mismo que tener 7
100 más 50 que es lo mismo que 7 a las
ahora me gustaría llamar la atención en
algo muy importante tenemos que
asegurarnos que la operación que estamos
haciendo es multiplicación porque por
ejemplo si yo tuviera 7 a la centésima
que suma a 7 a las 50 a va entonces el
asunto es completamente diferente
esta operación que acabamos de escribir
no se puede simplificar como las que
hemos venido haciendo entonces hay que
ser cuidadosos vamos a hacer más
entonces con lo que hemos venido
haciendo si yo tengo dos a la octava que
multiplica dos a la veinteava pues
entonces es simplemente 2 a la 28ava así
de simple
ahora vamos a ver un ejemplo que es
interesante entonces qué pasa si yo
tengo dos a la 8 + 2 a la 8
y justo acabo de decir que la regla no
se aplica cuando yo tengo una suma pero
si observamos con más cuidado este
ejemplo en particular podemos ver que
estamos sumando dos veces 2 a la 8 lo
que podemos reescribirlo como dos veces
2 a la 8
y entonces esto lo puedo reescribir como
el producto de 2 a la 1 que multiplica 2
a la 8 y entonces ahora sí aplicando
esta propiedad de la multiplicación en
los exponentes puedo sumarlos y me queda
2 a la novena
hagamos uno más qué pasa si yo tengo
cinco al menos 100 x 5 a la 102 bueno
pues esto me va a quedar 5 al cuadrado 5
a la 2 porque simplemente hago la la
suma de menos 100 más 102 y obtengo 2
claro y además 5 al cuadrado es igual a
así que esta es la primera regla para
los exponentes y hay una segunda que se
deriva de esta que seguro la base ya la
conoces o la vas a comprender muy fácil
vamos a ver
ahora vamos con este otro ejercicio que
puede parecer un poco engañoso al
principio que pasa si tengo
qué pasa si tengo 29 dividido entre dos
a la 10
voy
vamos a tomar con cuidado las cosas pero
tenemos los elementos para trabajar con
esto es cuestión de reescribir y esto lo
podemos reescribir como 2 a la 9 que
está multiplicado
por 1 sobre 2 a la 10
esto ya lo sabemos estuvimos trabajando
en el vídeo de exponentes 2
y esto a su vez lo podemos reescribir
como 2 a la 9 que está haciendo x 2 al
menos 10 aquí lo único que hice fue
tomar este que se encuentra aquí y darle
la vuelta y escribir el exponente en
negativo y eso es parte de las leyes de
los exponentes
y regresamos a lo que estábamos haciendo
entonces tenemos 29 menos 10 es menos 1
y 2 a la menos uno es igual a un medio
y ya estamos
sólo es cuestión de aplicar las leyes de
los exponentes siempre que tenga un
exponente en el denominador lo puedo
reescribir como negativo
así que directamente podría yo escribir
esto como dos a la nueve menos diez que
es igual a dos al menos uno que es igual
a un medio como ya habíamos visto bien
pues hagamos más ejercicios
qué pasa si tengo
10 a la 200 a va dividido entre 10 a la
50 pues esto simplemente va a ser 10 a
la 200 menos 50 que es 10 a las 150 y ya
estamos listos
de la misma manera qué pasa si tengo 7 a
la 40 dividido entre 7 a la menos 5
bueno pues esto simplemente lo puedo
poner como 7 a la 40 menos 5 negativo
o sea menos -5 y esto es igual a 40
menos -5 es 40 57 a la 45
muy bien porque esto también podríamos
verlo de otra manera yo podría
reescribir esto como
7 a la 40 multiplicado
7 a las 5 eso me lo dice la segunda ley
de los exponentes lo que está aquí en la
parte de abajo del consciente y esto
simplemente es 7 a la 45 como ya
esperábamos de acuerdo
bien como ya sabemos en los casos en los
que se trata de que ambos números con
exponentes tienen la misma base como es
el caso en un cociente como el que
tenemos aquí lo único que hacemos es
restar los exponentes
y bien esto nos da pie a poner otro
ejercicio que es un poquito interesante
que vamos a ver con cuidado
y el ejercicio es este es si tengo un 2
a la 9 x 4 a la 100
bueno esto hay que aplicar aquí un par
de trucos que también te voy a enseñar
entonces esto yo lo puedo reescribir
2 a la 9 que multiplica a 2 al cuadrado
que es 4 que está elevado a la centésima
potencia
entonces la tercera regla que también
tengo enseñar en el próximo vídeo me
dice que cuando un número con un
exponente está elevado a otro exponente
los exponentes se multiplican que
entonces en este caso esto va a ser lo
mismo que tener 2 a la 9 que multiplica
a 2 a la 200 y por la primera regla de
los exponentes esto es igual a 2 a la
y en el próximo vídeo te voy a enseñar
esta tercera regla para estos casos de
números con un exponente que se elevan a
otra potencia
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo